[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: OK, hello everyone.
Thank you all for
coming this afternoon.
Dr. Paul Cohen is one of
America's most distinguished
classical saxophonist.
Having appeared as a soloist
for the San Francisco
Symphony, the Richmond
Symphony, the New Jersey
symphony, and many others.
He has published over 100
articles on the history
and lost literature of the
saxophone in prestigious music
journals.
His company To the
Four Publishers,
publishes repertoire
for saxophone ensembles
of all sizes.
Dr. Cohen frequently presents
lectures on the saxophone,
illustrating his talks with
rare instruments, manuscripts,
and archival material from his
extensive private collection.
Dr. Cohen holds
MM and DMA degrees
from the Manhattan
School of Music.
His teachers have included
Galon [INAUDIBLE] Joe Allard,
and Sigurd Rascher.
He is currently on the faculty
of the Manhattan School
of Music, the Mason Grove
School of the Arts, Rutgers
University, New York
University, Columbia University,
and the Aaron Copland School
of Music at Queens College.
So without further ado,
everyone give a warm
welcome to Doctor Paul Cohen.
PAUL COHEN: Thank you.
Thanks, very excited to be here.
I assume that everybody in
the audience is a saxophonist?
Is that right?
Yes?
Good.
Well, I thought I'd
start out by taking pity
on all of us saxophonists.
Throughout the years, we have
been given so many labels
and ascribed so many
different things.
Either we have been deified--
that's the original, by the way.
The early ones you see,
they were Fresco shops
to take out the saxophone.
But this is the original.
Or we have been vilified, as we
see a poster from Nazi Germany
where the saxophone was the
object of the degenerate art
music that was banned.
Or we have been embraced as
part of American culture,
as Norman Rockwell's "Saturday
Evening Post" magazine cover
from 1929.
Or we've been mysticized.
Or sometimes just part of
good old American culture.
But many of us don't really
understand where saxophone
came from or what it's about.
The saxophone was invented
by Adolphe Sax around 1840.
He was a Belgian
who moved to Paris,
and his intent was to make an
instrument for the orchestra.
Not for the jazz band, not
for the marching bands,
not for the military bands,
but for the orchestra.
And indeed, when he
made his saxophone,
he conceived of them
as a whole family.
Here is his original
sax patent of 1846,
which shows all of the different
sizes he was thinking of.
And they start out from
sopranino, to soprano, to alto,
to tenor, to baritone,
to bass, to contrabass.
And he spoke at length
of what his intent was
for making the saxophone.
He said, struck by the
various inconveniences,
I have been
searching for a means
to amend these by creating
an instrument which,
by the very character
of its voice,
approaches the
string instruments,
but which possesses much more
power and intensity than these.
This instrument
is the saxophone.
More than any other
instrument, the saxophone
is susceptible to
modify its tone in order
to give it the
mentioned qualities
and to conserve a perfect
evenness over its entire range.
I made them out of
copper, and in the shape
of a parabolic cone.
For embouchure the
saxophone is a mouthpiece
with a single reed, the
interior of which is expressly
bell shaped and that contracts
towards the part, which
it adapts to the body
of the instrument.
He's saying that he
made an instrument that
will have aspects of the
string instruments, aspects
of the woodwind instruments,
aspect of the brass
instruments, and with the
technical construction
of a conical bore
and a mouthpiece
of a certain shape to give
it this orchestral quality.
That was what he
intended for it.
Here's a contemporary showing
of the Saxophone family.
All the instruments from
sopranino to bass, and this
belongs to Sigurd Rascher,
a very famous saxophone
pioneer who lived in this
country for many, many years.
We don't know what
happened from that.
The saxophone had its early
start in the orchestra.
It was featured in an opera
by Halevy in the 1840s.
More famously we know a
piece by Georges Bizet,
the "L'Ariesienne
Suites" from the 1870s.
In opera, we have
Hamlet by Thomas,
and we have [INAUDIBLE]
by Massenet.
And then in the 20th
century, we have many pieces.
Some by Ravel,
some by Prokofiev,
some by Rachmaninoff,
some by Aaron Copland.
And it has had a small
but distinguished role
in the orchestra.
It also became part of the
military bands in France.
And it became very, very popular
as a wind band instrument.
In this country in the 1870s
through the result of Charles
Lefevbre from Europe
coming to this country
and being in the Gilmore,
and then the Sousa bands,
the saxophone began to become
a very popular instrument
in the United States
starting from the 1870s.
So much so that the Conn
company from Elkhart, Indiana
began making their
own instruments.
The first American made
instruments in the early 1890s.
And it became somewhat of a
very, very popular instrument.
Jazz didn't arrive on the
scene until the 19 teens.
We're talking the 1890s.
The instrument was so popular
that it was used in churches.
It was used in community bands,
saxophone quartets, vaudeville,
some burlesque, the
Chautauqua circuit.
All these things around
the turn of the century
became fertile venues for
the saxophone to be used.
And the saxophone was also
an agent of social progress.
Because in the
1880s and '90s, we
had women become professional
saxophone soloists.
This is Bessie Mecklem.
She and her uncle formed
a harp and saxophone
duet in New Jersey.
And they toured
regionally for many years.
It was a professional ensemble.
Women really making
it in a profession
that most people had
just assigned to men.
In fact, Bessie was the
first saxophonist to record.
In 1892 she made 10 cylinder
sides at the Edison Studios
in West Orange, New Jersey.
The first saxophonist
to record was a woman.
Later on at the
turn of the century,
we had women saxophone quartets.
These are the Schuster sisters
from St. Louis promoting
for the Conn company from 1904.
And this group toured
for quite a while,
and was one of any number
of women who were doing it
as a profession on the
saxophone in the early part
of the century.
As the saxophone continued to
increase in its popularity,
it became more involved in
community bands, ragtime music,
show music, and then
in the late 19 teens,
it became a late comer to
this new music called jazz.
And then once it
became to be identified
into jazz in the
early 1920s, it became
one of the predominant
jazz instruments.
But again, somewhat
of a late comer
to jazz compared to the cornet,
compared to the clarinet,
compared to the trombone.
As I continue with this lecture,
this kind of breezy involvement
in the saxophone,
I want to encourage
you to ask any questions you may
have about any of these things.
There's certainly a
lot of information
we're talking about.
So as we start to see the varied
ways that the saxophone was
used, we shouldn't be so much
pitying the saxophone for being
pigeonholed into this
or that, but really
kind of amazed at how many
different venues the saxophone
was used in, and is
still used today.
As the saxophone
was a new instrument
and not encumbered by traditions
of centuries as the other wind
instruments had, it
was not rigid to how
the instrument was to be
conceived, or designed,
or made, or sounded.
It was a fertile ground for
experimentation and innovation,
not unlike the Google
culture that I've
been fortunate to visit today.
So I thought I would show
you some of the experiments
and some of the innovations
that took place.
Before then, I wanted to
just play an audio clip.
As today we are always
looking for the most advanced,
the most technologically
innovative either circuitry,
or software, or gadget that
will make things easy to do,
I thought I'd play for you
a very, very early clip
of a saxophonist from 1899
playing on a very, very
old saxophone.
A state of the art
instrument of its time
that, if we were
to see today, we
could hardly play
a C scale on it.
It would be so awkward,
it would be so tight,
it would be so difficult to do.
But I wanted to show you what
these people could play on,
these antiquated
old instruments.
So we're going to be
hearing Jean Moeremans, who
was a saxophonist
with Sousa Band,
at the very early part
of the 20th century,
around 1900, 1890s
or so, playing
the "Carnival of Venice."
[MUSIC PLAYS]
Can we just apply
one here as well?
It's obviously
gone a bit softer.
[INAUDIBLE]
Now, that's amazing that someone
could play on that instrument.
That's the equivalent today
of our having a regular work
day on dial-up instead
of what we are using now
with our internet speeds.
So it's really
fascinating for me
to hear somebody play at a
virtuoso level on instruments
that look to our eyes and
ears to be so primitive,
yet to them was state of
the art manufacturing.
What they could do with it then
is really quite remarkable.
And that's what the saxophone
sounded like at that time.
I thought to play for you yet
another early, early clip.
This is the earliest commercial
saxophone recording we have.
Eugene Coffin was considered
the Kenny G of his day.
He was a very popular
performing artist.
So popular, in fact,
that he was one
of the guest artists for William
McKinley's inauguration, which
may explain something
about his presidency.
We're going to hear him
play in what is the earliest
recording of a commercial
saxophonist playing something
called Sea Flower Polka.
And you'll hear his
dazzling triple tonguing.
As the custom with
cylinders of the time,
they announce the piece on
the cylinder before it plays.
[RECORDING STARTS]
[INAUDIBLE]
And his brother, Harry.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
Thank you, Eugene Coffin.
Now we come back to the
innovations of the saxophone.
In the post World War I
economic and social euphoria,
in the roaring '20s, there
were no holds barred.
As people were feeling economic
prosperity that was unrivaled,
and they were searching
out more and more,
and technology was becoming
more and more prevalent.
It was a wholesale
change in lifestyle,
and entertainment,
and expectations.
The saxophone was right
in the middle of this.
As vaudeville and other
entertainment venues
were becoming more
and more popular,
and were reaching
more and more people,
there was an attempt
to try to find
more and more ways
to reach a very
hungry population for novelty.
One of the more interesting
ones was the slide saxophone
made by Reiffel and
Husted in Chicago in 1926.
This is what you
would think it is.
It's a slide saxophone.
This, of course, comes
from my collection.
And I'll show you a little
clip as to what it sounds like.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
The practicality
of the instrument
was such that they
didn't make many of them.
It became instantly rare,
a wonderful collectible,
and an interesting example of
how innovations didn't always
make it to market.
Something that I
understand is also
part of the Google culture.
So we can celebrate
this some 100 years ago.
Some innovations,
though, worked very well.
In 1929, the Conn
Company, out of nowhere,
came with the
amazing Conn-o-Sax.
This is an
extraordinary saxophone
that's pitched not in the
key of e-flat like an alto,
but the key of F,
like an English horn.
And with its novel shape, but
with an extended key range--
from low A to high G
instead of the typical low B
flat to high F--
it produced a visual novelty
and a tonal novelty that
is capturing an enchanting.
And I'm going to play for
you a little excerpt of what
the Conn-o-Sax sounds like.
This is me in a performance
with organ some years ago.
[MUSIC - "AMAZING GRACE"]
The amazing and
haunting Conn-o-Sax.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it's
a beautiful sound,
it sounds like a
mellow English horn.
PAUL COHEN: Thank you.
Leave me your card
when you leave.
AUDIENCE: Does it have
an English horn's bell?
I can't tell from the picture.
PAUL COHEN: Oh,
look on that side.
AUDIENCE: Over there.
Oh, it does look
like [INAUDIBLE]
PAUL COHEN: Yeah, it has
a bulb at the bottom.
And we think that that adds
to the acoustical nature of it
to give it that little
haunting darker woodish
quality of an English horn.
Sad tale of the Conn-o-sax,
it was made in 1929 right
when the depression
was coming, and right
when there was a sea change in
the whole economic and social
aspect of America.
Conn made a
brilliant instrument,
but they miscalculated in
marketing a little bit.
They put it in the
key of F, not E flat,
which guarantee that there
was no music written for it.
They priced it as expensive
as a regular saxophone,
so you had to pay a
considerable amount of money
to be able to buy one.
They advertised it as a
vaudevillian instrument.
They showed people of
it dancing like this,
and having around
there, and they said,
you have to have this novelty
instrument for your act.
Well, there were no more acts.
Vaudeville was in steep decline.
Entertainment which was changing
with the advent of talkies--
we call them sound
movies these days--
and more extensive
radio highways.
And records now that
were more than the wax
cylinders, and more than
just the acoustic '78s.
Everything was changing
about what we were hearing
and what we expected from
music, not to mention
the ascendancy of jazz.
So they made a great
instrument, marketed it poorly,
made it expensive, made it
impractical because of the key,
and put it out on the market.
They advertised
it for six months.
And then we lose sight of it.
We would find that buried in
catalogs for another 10 years.
As such, we know of only perhaps
25 of these to still exist.
And you heard one of
them from my collection.
So again, remarkably
innovative and boldly produced
instruments, but did not have
the effect that it wanted.
As opposed to Billy True.
Billy True was a musician in the
1920s who was a regular roving
musician.
He later went back to
work at the company
that his father worked
in, the Wheeling Steel
Factory, a giant complex
on the Monongahela River
in West Virginia.
But he kept up his
saxophone interests
in a very different way.
Billy True found a way to
play three saxophones at once.
He did that by modifying
three saxophones
from the Conn company, two
altos and one C melody.
And you can't see
it so well on this.
But at the bottom here is a
platform, you have foot pedals.
He's able to manipulate the
keys for the middle saxophone
with the foot pedals.
And with extended
key work on one hand
and extended key work
on the other hand,
he could play the full range
of all three saxophones.
Something very practical.
And he did this in
the 1930s and '40s
as part of a hobby,
and part of his
reaching out professionally.
Do you want to know
what it sounded like?
No?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PAUL COHEN: Flash drive.
AUDIENCE: It's right
back up to here.
OK.
PAUL COHEN: We love Billy True.
So we're going to go back in
time now to the heyday of radio
where there were hobby hours,
and there were variety shows,
and there were all kinds of
entertainments on the radio.
Why radio?
They hadn't perfected
internet streaming yet,
TV was still a novelty that was
still being experimented with.
So we're going to hear Billy
True play on the radio.
[RECORDING PLAYS]
RADIO ANNOUNCER:
Our next [INAUDIBLE]
is a young fellow who lives
in Steubenville, Ohio.
His name is Billy True.
For the past few years
he's been working
on the pipes [INAUDIBLE] at
the Wheeling Steel Company.
But now he's come to New York
to commercialize the hobby he
follows during his spare time.
Billy, what is your hobby?
BILLY TRUE: I play saxophone.
RADIO ANNOUNCER: Well,
so many people do that.
BILLY TRUE: I know,
Mr. [INAUDIBLE],,
but I play saxophones.
RADIO ANNOUNCER: Saxophones?
You mean two saxophones
at the same time?
BILLY TRUE: No, I play three
saxophones at the same time.
RADIO ANNOUNCER: Uh oh.
Now wait a minute, Billy.
Playing one saxophone calls
for two hands and a mouth.
Therefore, playing three
saxophones a the same time
would call for six hands
and a mouth like Joey Brown.
BILLY TRUE: Well I think
you can vouch for the fact
that I haven't six hands,
and I'm not Joey Brown.
RADIO ANNOUNCER: No, you're not.
Well then tell us,
how do you do it?
BILLY TRUE: I have
a way of putting
three regular sized saxophone
mouthpieces in a row,
open my mouth wide, take
a deep breath, and blow.
RADIO ANNOUNCER: That
takes care of explaining
how you blow three
saxophones, but Billy,
how do you play them?
BILLY TRUE: I play two of
the saxophones with my hands,
and the third
saxophone with my feet.
RADIO ANNOUNCER:
With your shoes on?
BILLY TRUE: Well, yes!
RADIO ANNOUNCER: Well
Billy, perhaps I better
stop asking so many
questions and let you get out
of this predicament yourself.
Try it.
BILLY TRUE: I play two of
the saxophones with my hands.
On those two horns, I
have added extra keys
making it possible to
play each with one hand.
RADIO ANNOUNCER: Well now
that's two out of three,
and a mighty good [INAUDIBLE].
But playing the third
saxophone with shoes on's
going to be interesting.
BILLY TRUE: I've worked out
a mechanical arrangement
of foot pedals so that with my
feet I can play all the notes.
RADIO ANNOUNCER: I see.
You blow the saxophone
with your mouth,
and finger the keys
with your feet.
Well all right, Billy,
let's hear you play them.
Going onto the stand on
which he has the three
separate saxophones just like
you see them in any orchestra.
the one he plays with
his feet is in the middle
and has wires going
all over the place.
And if he ever figured
out which wire is which,
we'll have [INAUDIBLE]
for backup.
Well, he's signaled
that he's ready.
Here goes three saxophones
played at one time by one man.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
Thank you, Billy True.
PAUL COHEN: And
thank you Billy True.
So that's the kind of innovation
that you don't often see.
And I have to tell you, I
own these instruments now.
The picture was taken from
my little museum in my home.
The design is amazing,
and the craftsmanship
in getting this to
work is stunning.
Not to mention having to
develop an embouchure that
can accommodate three
mouthpieces at once.
Now that takes training.
So there's uncommon dedication
for a very limited and unique
usage.
As we're talking about
C melodies and altos
from the 1920s, I thought
to show you some instruments
that I brought with me that
are a little bit different
than what you might expect.
We all know about the
soprano saxophone.
And most of us know
the soprano saxophone
as being the small, straight
member of the saxophone family.
But many of us don't realize
that the soprano saxophone
was made in different
shapes, if not sizes.
And beyond the straight one,
we have ones that are curved.
They look like this.
This Is a venerable
curved soprano from 1925,
made by the Busher Company
from Elkhart, Indiana.
These have a
different sound than
the commercial straight
instruments of our time.
And when played with
the right mouthpiece
to get more of a classical
tone, it can sound like this.
And let's see if
you can recognize
the piece I'm playing.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
Anybody recognize that?
AUDIENCE: "Bolero?"
PAUL COHEN: "Bolero."
And that's an actual
saxophone solo
that's in "Bolero," along with
every other orchestral wind
instrument.
And it was written in
the late 1920s by Ravel.
It's become one of the more
popular orchestra works.
And that was written
for the saxophone.
And you're hearing it in a
curved saxophone with a very
classical mouthpiece to give it
more of an orchestral quality.
A very different
sound that we often
hear the soprano in the
commercial pop and jazz
contexts.
But Adolphe Sax
didn't stop there,
because he also made
an instrument higher
than the soprano.
And that would be the sopranino.
Most of the time when
you see the sopranino--
if you ever see the sopranino,
and I hope for your sakes
that you don't see
the sopranino often.
But most of the times
when you see it,
it's a straight instrument.
It's a very tiny instrument.
But some of us have
ones that are curved.
And this little pest
of an instrument
is as cute to look
at as it is to play.
But I'm also going to play for
you an orchestral excerpt that
was originally written
for the sopranino.
But when you hear today
in other instrumentation,
you won't hear the sopranino.
Let's see if you can
identify this piece.
Here's a hint, it's
also from the 1920s.
An orchestral work.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
Anyone heard of that before?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, "Rhapsody in Blue."
The famous "Rhapsody in
Blue" by George Gershwin
was originally written
for the Paul Whiteman
band, Paul Whiteman's
jazz band as part
of an experiment in modern
music from the 1924 Aeolian Hall
concert.
And for that combination
of Paul Whiteman's band,
he had a sopranino saxophone.
And that piece
was scored for it.
Later on, Ferde Grofe, who was
the arranger of the work who
was the one who orchestrated it,
made a version for orchestra.
And he took out all the
colorful jazz instruments
and more colorful sounding
less common instruments,
and replaced them with
oboes, and bassoons,
and other instruments.
And now the original version
is being played more and more
often.
You can actually hear
the sopranino chirp
in with that about 2/3
of the way through.
So this is the E flat sopranino
in its cute curved version.
It's an octave higher
than the alto saxophone.
And I'm conducting a large
saxophone choir on Saturday
at Stanford University.
If you want to hear these in
abundance, gather your courage
and come out and hear a whole
choir of saxophones playing,
including the sopranino, all
the way down to the contrabass.
Well let's go on.
I talk a lot throughout
the country about saxophone
and its history, but
rarely do I have a chance
to talk to an audience whose
mission is in innovation.
So I'm enjoying the
opportunity bringing up
aspects of the
saxophone's history
where there were
innovations that were going
on 100 years ago, 80 years ago.
And we've talked about
some of them in the past.
I'm very happy to now show you
yet another one that failed.
Around 1940, the Selmer
Company, an agent
had a company in
the United States,
came up with the
padless saxophone.
This is a saxophone that doesn't
have traditional pads that
cover the holes, but it has
metal disks instead of pads.
So these metal disks would
then descend on leather gaskets
to create the seal.
In many ways, this is
a very innovative idea.
Because it had certain
technical expediencies
that could allow
us to play more.
It didn't really
work out that way.
And I'm going to show you
this by playing a clip.
This clip I'm going to play
you is unfortunately overlaid
with my voice, because it was
part of a CD that was done.
So in order to best appreciate
what happened with this,
you're going to have to
hear me speaking on the clip
as you hear the
padless saxophone.
PAUL COHEN (ON RECORDING): These
innovative instruments, called
Selmer USAs, do not have pads.
In place are flat
and thin metal disks.
The tone holes themselves are
line with a leather gasket
that provides the seal
when the key is closed.
In theory, this provides
a faster, truer action
and eliminates pad
wear and regulation.
In practice, though, the leather
gasket proved problematic.
As it dried out, it no longer
retained its supple shape
and sealing capacity.
Unless you replaced the
leather gaskets regularly,
the result was an increasingly
leaking instrument
whose key noise made it
difficult for recording
and radio broadcasting.
[CLATTERING SOUNDS]
PAUL COHEN: And so went
the padless saxophone.
At the end of World War
II, because of the research
and the war effort for materials
to help with the war effort,
this brand new material
burst on the scene.
I feel like I'm
in "The Graduate."
It was plastic.
Plastic was a brand new element,
and one innovative Englishman
thought to use this new plastic
material for a saxophone.
And he came out with the
remarkable Grafton Plastic
Alto.
For those of you who know a
little about saxophone lore,
the Grafton Plastic is
a very story of one.
Beautiful instrument.
I remember reading that
when it was introduced
into New York around 1954,
just when color television was
starting to be available,
one of the freelance artists
said, hey, this will be
a honey for color TV.
And it was also made very famous
through Charlie Parker, who
played the Grafton in this
very famous Massey Hall
concert in Toronto, Canada.
He agreed to play it,
no doubt, because he
had pawned his other
saxophones and had
nothing to play at that time.
And he agreed to play
the Grafton in Canada.
It has a beautiful sound,
but never caught on.
Because it looked too different.
The springing system
was quite innovative
and actually very efficient,
but too different for players
to really get comfortable with.
And unfortunately, when it
got damaged, it didn't dent,
it shattered.
It wasn't the kind of
plastic that we know today.
This is early plastic.
And even though the company had
offered a lifetime guarantee--
if it shatters,
we replace it-- it
wasn't enough for people to
become fully confident with it.
And so it did not
last very long.
It lasted perhaps
four or five years,
and then faded into
saxophone obscurity.
So this is the famous and
very storied plastic alto.
One unusual saxophone that's
making a comeback these days
is the very large
contrabass saxophone.
And here's a stunning
photo in all ways.
The contrabass saxophone is
an octave below the baritone--
yes, question?
AUDIENCE: How do you hold that?
PAUL COHEN: With a really great
harness and great stature.
You have to do calisthenics.
It also comes with a stand,
but he's doing it freestyle.
But just so you know,
the weight is not
supported just by the neck.
It's supported by the whole body
because of the harness with it.
And you really can't
move quickly with it.
And if you tried, you would
need a spotter to go with it.
The contrabass is an
octave below the baritone.
It was part of Sax's
original design,
but they were made in limited
quantity up to the 1920s.
But lately, a brilliant
saxophone inventor and designer
in Germany, Eppelsheim, started
making a contemporary one.
And this is one of those.
We're going to hear what
a contrabass sax sounds
like in an original work
written for contrabass saxophone
and soprano saxophone, the
"Hymn and Fuguing Tune No.
18" by Henry Cowell, who
lived a great deal of his life
in California.
This is a work written in
1964 for Sigurd Rascher,
and I'm sure I won't
get it to work.
I'm going to show you a picture
of two of my students playing
it in Queens.
And there'll be chances to
hear-- not them playing it,
the recording you'll
hear will be one
of my recordings of the piece.
I'm playing that
soprano saxophone
that you heard before,
and one of my colleagues
is playing the contrabass.
[MUSIC - "HYMN AND
FUGUING TUNE NO.
18"]
Can I get a job here now?
And that is the
contrabass saxophone.
This concludes the formal
part of my lecture,
but I thought I'd leave a little
time if there are any questions
that I can answer for you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Those
saxophones that they
used in the very late 1800s,
what were the mouthpieces made
out of?
Did they use plastic
in those days, or--
PAUL COHEN: Most of the
mouthpieces of the time
are made of wood.
And then in the early
part of the 20th century,
they were made out of
bakelite or a kind of plastic.
Some of them were
made out of aluminum
around the early teens.
But mostly were made of wood.
Sometimes the wood
was covered with metal
so that they wouldn't
warp so much.
And the plastic that
we used didn't come
into being until the 1930s.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: With the piece
that was just played,
it seems that when
the contrabass goes up
in the high range, it
seems significantly softer.
PAUL COHEN: That was a function
of the micing for the recording
session.
And if you were to
hear it done in live,
you would not hear
that disparity.
Were there other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
on the Conn-o-Sax,
is the timbral difference mainly
from the spherical attachment
on the bell, or are
there other differences?
PAUL COHEN: No, there are
many other differences.
The spherical
attachment of the bell
is just one component of
ameliorating or masking
the sound.
In part, the bell has
three open resonance holes,
one at either end and
one towards the player,
not towards the listener.
So that way it deliberately
doesn't allow some of the lower
resonance to go forward.
That helps it darken the sound.
But you also have the inherent
bore of the instrument
itself, and most
importantly, the mouthpiece
that goes with it, which is
designed to have that darker,
richer sound.
So those three things
together helped
to create the uniqueness
of the timbre.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PAUL COHEN: Yes?
AUDIENCE: For a
time I've wondered,
what would happen if you
were to mostly just cut off
the bell of a saxophone?
Would it make mainly
just the same sound?
PAUL COHEN: It would
make the same sound.
It would really toy
with the intonation,
and you'd have to be careful
that you don't cut yourself.
But the sound would be the same.
There would be other
mechanical issues
that would get a
little bit screwed up
because of the linkages.
But the sound would be the same.
It'd just not go as low.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You talk
about innovations
through the '50s
was the last one.
What has happened since then?
More changes in sax?
Or do you feel that
it's become more static,
and there's less
experimentation going on?
PAUL COHEN: There have been no
fewer innovations in saxophones
since then, but they've been
more in manufacturing, and more
in consistency, and how the
instrument's put together,
and a more sophisticated
design of the instrument
to improve the ergonomics,
to improve the intonation.
We now have soprano saxophones
with detachable necks,
which is an innovation
that wasn't available.
And the detachable necks,
the different shapes
of the necks give
different timbres
and different comfort levels
of playing, is one example.
So it's become
unfortunately prohibitively
expensive to be as
innovative today
as it was back in these times.
Although today we
still have someone
who has made a saxophone with
a chromatic fingering system,
a unique, remarkably
acoustically well
derived way of
play the saxophone.
You have to relearn how
to play the instrument.
Much like Billy True's three
saxophones with one player,
this has an innovation
that is extraordinary,
but is unfortunately
impractical.
With today's modern
technique, we
have developed one
handed saxophones
that have been useful
for players who have lost
the use of one of their hands.
I have some one handed
saxophones from the 1920s,
but they're not nearly
as innovative or as
technically advanced as the
ones that are being made today.
Some of them combine
micro electronics
to help with the
fingering systems.
So there are those
kinds of innovations,
but they're not as
bold or as striking
because it's too
expensive to try that
without a certain market for it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There's been
a lot of innovation
in a lot of
instruments these days,
but it's not just
in the manufacturing
of the instrument.
It's been with cybernetic
editions and enhancements,
like the [? Max ?] Violin.
I know that in the
wind area, people
are tracking the movement
of the instrument.
They're applying sensors to
the keypads for extra effects.
Can you speak to that and
what's going on with saxophones?
PAUL COHEN: Well, we have a
lot of electronic enhancements
that go with the saxophones.
Like the MIDI controllers
that are saxophones.
And there's saxophones
in fingering only,
they don't bear any native
acoustical relationship to it.
But yet we play them
like saxophones,
and we can synthesize sounds,
and do all kinds of things
with it.
And that's used in a lot
of contemporary music.
There are a lot of
other enhancements
that we are experimenting
with the instruments
by putting on different
weights, different masses
to try to change the residence
patterns from the outside.
There's a lot of
contention as to what
the materials of the
instrument are made of,
and what coating it has, and
how that affects the resonance
patterns, and how that
may go into manufacturing.
So there are these kind of
things that are going on.
And there's no lack of any
acoustical studies as to what's
happening with the instrument
that can be changed, either
to enhance the traditional
view of the saxophone,
or to propel it into a
more contemporary usage.
So those are some examples.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
do some modern players prefer
to play on these
older saxophones
from 60, or 70, or 80
years ago, or is there
a general preference that
new instruments are better?
PAUL COHEN: I'm still living.
[LAUGHTER] I guess you'd
call me a modern player.
And I play a lot on
these instruments.
The soprano that you saw me play
is one of two main performance
sopranos that I use,
and you heard it
in the recording of the
piece we just heard.
A lot of it has
to do with what we
listen for in the tone quality.
There are many
modern players today
who prefer this tone
quality, and will
play the vintage
instruments, even though they
have significant disadvantages.
The ergonomics are not as easy.
The intonation is not as easy.
And they go out of
regulation quite a bit.
But yet we put up with them,
because the newer instruments
just don't have that same sound.
So you see a very
interesting cross-section,
a significant but
minor percentage
of people who gravitate
towards this kind of sound
for the music they play
will play these instruments.
And they're still available.
And when properly, if
not severely regulated,
they can be as
professionally functional
as any other instrument.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I feel like
sometimes life would
be easier if there was a C sax.
And there is a C saxophone,
but we don't see it ever.
Do you think that the
C saxophone could ever
make a comeback?
PAUL COHEN: Well, C saxophones
were not uncommon in the 1920s.
In fact, the C Tenor, which
you call the C Melody,
was the most sold
saxophone of the era.
And along with that
is the C soprano.
The main sopranos
in the key of C. I
have many of them
in my collection.
It might make things easier.
But then again, we can simply
learn to transpose up a step
as I do often.
The issue with a C soprano is
that it's a little smaller,
and they just don't play or
tune as well as the B flat ones.
The C tenor was made
as a home instrument.
And in a lot of
the advertisements
that you would see
in the 1920s, you
would see the family
at the dinner,
gathered around the piano for
the evening's entertainment.
Remember, this was before
anything was streaming.
And in fact, was before
radio was that current,
and there was no TV.
So what we would
do after dinner,
besides gone down to
a local apothecary
and having a malted
or a phosphate,
would be to gather on a piano.
And you see this picture of
the father playing piano,
and one of the family
members looking over
a shoulder with a C tenor like
this, playing off the piano
part in C, because that
was able to do that.
So not too long ago, a company
came out with a C tenor.
Antigua, I think was
the name, or Antilla.
And unfortunately it didn't sell
very well, because two reasons.
There wasn't that
much of an interest,
and it seems that every C melody
that was made the 1920s still
exists.
And they come back to haunt
us, because they're everywhere.
And then we have no use for
them, and only some of them
are really, really well made.
So I don't think
there's going to be
much of a future for the C. But
I could probably interest you
in a transposing coursebook.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: OK, one more.
AUDIENCE: What would they do
with reeds in the early days
of saxophones?
PAUL COHEN: What we do today.
We curse at them.
We berate them.
We mash them.
We maneuver them.
We kick them.
We play them.
We discard them.
AUDIENCE: How would
they make them?
Did they mass produce
them, or did you
have to make them by
hand in the early days?
PAUL COHEN: They were mass
produced in ways not dissimilar
to today, except today we have
more sophisticated machinery.
But yes, they had
to be hand cut,
but they did have
machines that would
do a lot of the bulk of the
maneuvering, lathes and things
of that sort to do that.
But today, the ability to make
many more reeds at even closer
tolerances is very active.
But then we have to look
at the quality of the cane.
If they harvest it too
soon, if it grows well,
if they don't cure it well
enough so that when it
comes to us it's ready to play.
So there are a lot of
factors going into it.
But in a sense, the procedure
from cane stalk to reed
is not dissimilar
today that it was then.
Yes?
I'm sorry, I just--
AUDIENCE: What do you
think of plastic reeds?
PAUL COHEN: We're at
Google here, right?
So I can get technical.
I don't like plastic reeds.
However, the
synthetic resin reeds
that are being made today--
which are not plastic, per se,
but it's not organic material--
have great promise.
I actually use them
from time to time.
They have several advantages,
several disadvantages.
But in the most current
manifestations of those things,
mostly promoted by the Legere
company, they actually work,
and I know a lot of
colleagues who use them,
and they sound pretty good
on them./ so they've entered
the stable of what can work.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are composers
composing today
for orchestral music
with saxophone?
PAUL COHEN: Constantly.
It has become much
more accepted voice
in a lot of orchestral
works these days.
And so you'll hear it more,
and more, and more, and more.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So we see many
innovations that didn't stick.
Are there any major
innovations that did stick?
PAUL COHEN: Well yes, in fact.
Here's an example of one.
This is a modern
curved sopranino
that was made for me
by the Rampone company.
And the ability to be able
to make an instrument that
is professionally functional
requires quite a bit
of not just artistry, but the
technique of manufacturing.
As I mentioned earlier, we
have the two neck soprano
saxophones, which is
an innovation that
has only in less than 20 or
30 years become standard.
We have the innovation of
the new contrabass saxophone
that we saw.
And other manufacturing
techniques
that make the instruments
more consistent and just more
viable.
We have the soprillo
saxophone, which
is an even smaller version of
the sopranino that is something
that could not have been made
because there was no ability
to make that.
It's amazing, though.
That's about this big, and
is in the key of B flat.
AUDIENCE: Have there
been more recent attempts
at making plastic saxophones?
PAUL COHEN: Yes.
In Asia there's a
company that has
been making a new kind
of plastic saxophone.
And it's been targeted
through the student group,
and it's very new.
Made in the last two years.
And some people are
encouraged by it.
There's no reason why you
can't make a plastic saxophone.
Because the tone quality
of the instrument
is solely a function of
the bore dimensions and not
of the materials.
So you should be able to
get a plastic saxophone
that if it's internally made
according to the design,
should sound just fine.
Years ago they once
made a blindfold test
of a very famous clarinetist
playing behind a screen.
He played on his
R13 Buffet clarinet,
and he played on a garden hose.
And people couldn't
hear the difference.
AUDIENCE: What about
the mouthpiece?
PAUL COHEN: Same mouthpiece.
Give us a break.
It was the same mouthpiece.
And of course, the garden
hose had some holes in it,
which were carefully put in.
The clarinet is a
cylindrical bore,
the garden hose is a cylindrical
bore, no kinks in this hose.
And because you had a very
fine player playing it,
he was able to play
it the same, people
could not tell the difference.
So that's a very upsetting
story that people
don't like to tell very much.
But that's simply
an acoustic reality.
So technically, you
should be able to make
a plastic saxophone.
Now, there are other issues
about why a plastic saxophone
may not work.
If you're going to
have all the joints,
mechanical things
made of plastic,
that may wear out
more than if you
have traditional metal and
traditional bearings on that.
But that's another issue.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I don't know if
this applies to saxophones,
too, but I've tried a
metal clarinet before
and that sounds totally
different from the wood
or plastic ones.
So do you think if he had
put like a metal clarinet,
would it sound the same?
Because I feel like
that would've not.
PAUL COHEN: I'm sorry to say
that the metal clarinet can
sound like a regular clarinet.
Now, the metal
clarinets were designed
to be used as
marching instruments,
and to be used as
student instruments.
They weren't made with the
same care as traditional ones.
But if you were to
get a metal clarinet--
and I've seen some
metal clarinets,
and I've had some
of my colleagues
play with their
professional mouthpieces
and their professional
tonal imagery on it,
they sound pretty good.
So you know, if we close our
eyes, and numb our fingers,
and just play what's
in front of us,
you'd be amazed at how
similar those can be.
Any other questions?
I want to thank you
all for coming today.
It's my pleasure to
be here at Google.
And I hope you learned something
about the saxophone today.
[APPLAUSE]